[Musica]
sono qui oggi per parlarvi di
intelligenza artificiale e di come
l'intelligenza artificiale cambierà il
modo in cui lavoriamo e il modo stesso
in cui percepiamo il lavoro prima di
tutto cosa l'intelligenza artificiale
ne abbiamo tantissimi esempi nel nella
cultura pop e nei film nei media è
interessante vedere come nei film spesso
a gta esiti tragici e sono intelligenze
molto simile a quella umana in grado di
interagire con noi e di risolvere
tantissimi problemi differenti è così il
livello di intelligenza artificiale che
abbiamo oggi no
sviluppiamo tantissimi livelli intesi
entrati fissare diversi per problemi
diversi e intelligenza artificiale non è
in grado di comportarsi come un essere
umano
c'è un test interessantissimo sviluppato
da uno dei più grandi matematici del
ventesimo secolo
alan turing in cui un giudice viene
messo in contatto testuale quindi
tramite una chat con un essere umano è
un computer che pretende di essere umano
se il giudice non riesce a distinguere
efficacemente quale dei due all'essere
umano
abbiamo passato il test abbiamo una
macchina pensante abbiamo un
intelligenza artificiale forte e
interessantissimo il film sulla sua vita
che hanno fatto un paio di anni fa
limitation game invito tutti a vederlo
ma quindi l'applichiamo tecniche
differenti quindi algoritmi differenti
allenati su istanze differenti ha
problemi differenti e questi problemi
vanno dai più disparati da fini malefici
atti a distrarsi dal nostro lavoro atti
a farci perdere tempo e soldi che
sfortunatamente hanno un grandissimo
successo con me come le pubblicità
personalizzate online le pubblicità
personalizzate online i pop up che
vedete apparire ogni giorno navigando
sono sviluppate sono scelte
appositamente per voi da algoritmi che
li profilano che quindi raccolgono tutte
le vostre interazioni
on line tutti i vostri acquisti perché
ha un profilo dei vostri gusti dei
vostri desideri
però in realtà hanno anche fini nobili
come per esempio la diagnosi medica sono
dietro tantissimi algoritmi che
analizzano per esempio le vostre
scansioni hicks rai sono presenti in
tutti i vostri telefoni il
riconoscimento facciale riconoscimento
vocale e per esempio negli aerei
pilotano le aree la maggior parte del
tempo di volo un aereo pilotato da un
computer e non dal pilota
il pilota neri controllo solo per più o
meno 7 8 minuti ogni volo io nello
specifico lavoro nella plicazione di
queste tecniche nell'industria quindi
utilizziamo queste tecniche per
implorare la produzione industriale di
caso specifico è un problema chiamato
car painting le macchine vengono
verniciate da questi robot passano
attraverso il robot libero si leverà
iniziano automaticamente e
successivamente passano all'assemblaggio
per passare dalla produzione della
macchina rossa a una gialla
devo prima pulire completamente il robot
caricare il nuovo colore e iniziare la
produzione
il cambio tra due colori dipende in
tempo di durata e operazioni da fare
da quali sono questi due colori per
esempio è molto più semplice passare da
una produzione di osso a una produzione
di arancione
il nostro obiettivo è diminuire il
numero totale di riconfigurazione del
robot quindi di cambi colore e cercare
di fare solo quelli più veloci perché
per tre punti principali il primo è che
ogni riconfigurazione è uno spreco in
termini economici ed ecologici di acqua
componenti chimici per pulire robot e di
tutto il colore presente nel robot
il secondo è che uno spreco di
produzione è solo un costo per l'azienda
un robot che sta venendo riconfigurato
non sta producendo niente che posso
vendere mantenendo ad esempio dell'aereo
un aereo che non sta volando non sta
producendo nessun utile per la compagnia
inoltre è la parte della produzione che
richiede la maggior parte di manodopera
quindi diminuendo il numero totale di
riconfigurazione e diminuendo la loro
durata diminuisco l'apporto umano alla
produzione quindi aumento la
produttività oraria dei singoli
dipendenti
questo è uno dei tantissimi esempi in
cui l'intelligenza artificiale sta
avvenendo e sta cambiando il modo in cui
produciamo e con e contribuisce
aumentare la nostra singola produttività
in una singola fabbrica è molto semplice
gestire un singolo o se devo gestire
decine di robot che lavorano in
centinaia di macchine di decine di
colori differenti è praticamente
impossibile per un essere umano
possiamo avere solo ha subito soluzioni
approssimative in cui non riesco ad
aggiungere il risparmio massimo di
risorse in cui vado sempre a sprecare
quindi più componenti chimici acqua e
lavoro perché un computer riesce a fare
decisioni migliori delle nostre in
questa situazione perché riesce a
raccogliere più informazioni quindi
riesce ad avere accesso a idee i dati di
vendita riesce avere accesso a tutto lo
stato
allo stato attuale dei robot la loro
configurazione e riesce a tenere in
considerazione tutte le informazioni dei
prodotti in oltre a una maggiore potenza
computazionale riesce a valutare tutti i
possibili scenari che nel caso di una
fabbrica di un esempio come il
precedente sono nell'ordine dei miliardi
quindi impossibili per non essere umano
e riesce a elaborare tutte le
informazioni che aveva visto in
precedenza e infine obiettivo per
esempio un manager che a un'auto rossa o
che predilige le macchine rosse
inconsciamente favore alla produzione di
auto rossa come sto dicendo questa è uno
dei tantissimi esempi in cui
l'intelligenza artificiale sta
rimpiazzando del lavoro sta togliendo
dei lavori molto semplice manuali e
rimpiazzandoli con per lasciare il posto
a lavori più alte di più alto livello
tecnologico
molte ricerche hanno cercato di aiutare
l'apporto di questa rivoluzione
tecnologica una delle più interessanti è
stata resa disponibile grazie al sito
web wheel club state mahjoub in cui
ognuno di voi può inserire la propria
professione e avrà come risultato la
probabilità di venire rimpiazzati da
robot e intelligenza artificiale con le
tecnologie al momento esistenti e quindi
preoccupatevi per l'attenzione e vi
auguro di consiglio dopo di forma
ricerca non adesso ma il ridurre il
numero di posti lavoro necessarie per
produrre lo stesso quantitativo di
risorse è un filo comune di tutte le
rivoluzioni industriali e ne abbiamo
tantissimi esempi questo chi sa dirmi
cosa questo vale è una seminatrice a un
prodotto montebellunese viene prodotto
più o meno 2 km da la casa la mia
famiglia
questa fino a 50 anni fa non esisteva
prima il lavoro di semina veniva
effettuato dalle mondine aldo giovanni e
giacomo
torna sempre tutte le presentazioni e
quindi ha rimpiazzato tantissimi lavori
però non ci troviamo con un grosso
problema disoccupazione al giorno d'oggi
com'è possibile semplice questa è la
prima teoria da adesso in poi ci saranno
solo teorie sono due posti due possibili
scenari di cosa accadrà da oggi nei
prossimi vent'anni
e la prima è la storia si ripete
reagiremo a questa perdita questa
emorragia di posti di lavoro come
abbiamo reagito tutte le precedenti
rivoluzioni industriali quindi creando
le nuove tecnologie eliminano posti di
lavoro ma ne creeranno altrettanti la
seconda è che il cambiamento sarà troppo
radic e troppo drastico e troppo rapido
per lasciare il mercato di organizzarsi
autonomamente e quindi dovremo
intervenire dal punto di vista
legislativo
nella prima si sostiene che la creazione
di nuovi posti di lavoro grazie per
esempio alla robotica l'intelligenza
artificiale rimpiazza completamente i
precedenti assieme a un incremento dei
bisogni
50 anni fa non avevamo bisogno di
telefonini computer tutto il settore
informatico delle aziende sotto creato
negli ultimi 40 anni il settore della
comunicazione web di social media sono
tutti i lavori che siamo riusciti a
creare perché queste persone non
dovevano più lavorare nei campi
quindi sui lavori più tecnici in cui
l'essere umano riesce a dare un apporto
molto più importante rispetto a un puro
lavoro manuale
un esempio chiaro sono youtubers un
lavoro che fino a qualche anno fa
nessuno poteva pensare la seconda teoria
che il cambiamento sarà troppo veloce
per lasciare il mercato per organizzarsi
autonomamente e quindi dovremo
intervenire dal punto di vista
legislativo riusciamo a produrre lo
stesso quantitativo di risorse quindi lo
stesso benessere utilizzando meno
persone meno lavoro meno persone devono
lavorare o le persone devono lavorare di
meno quindi abbiamo gli esperimenti come
nei paesi nordici della riduzione
dell'orario lavorativo dalle 6 alle 8
ore
ho idee proposte di redditi unici
incondizionati
in questo caso si passerebbe
completamente a una nuova idea di lavoro
in cui io non lavoro più per il
sostentamento lavoro per scelta lavoro
per migliorare il mio status sociale ci
sono stati dei precedenti simili nella
prima rivoluzione industriale
quando quell aumento di produzione ha
portato la serie di nuovi diritti umani
come la riduzione come l'abolizione del
lavoro minorile
chi conosce quest'uomo mani alzate
ok questo è uno degli anni più ricchi al
mondo il fondatore della microsoft bill
gates come finanziare tutte queste
proposte
lì ho avuto in teoria molto interessante
che vi lascio come spunto di discussione
in cui sostiene io dovremo passare ogni
tecnologia chi era in piazza un singolo
posto di lavoro tanto quanto quel posto
di lavoro se intelligenza artificiale
guida il camion al posto del camionista
devo passare quella di intelligenza
tanta
o quanto un camionista se un singolo
computer rimpiazza un intero call center
pagherà le tasse tanto quanto in
consente per finanziare sistemi sociali
che abbiamo visto in precedenza quindi
per finire un attimo fare previsioni è
facile anche senza utilizzare
l'intelligenza della del gregge fare
predizioni azzeccate è molto complesso
quindi nessuno sa realmente cosa
succederà nei prossimi 20 anni
queste sono teorie però sicuramente
succederà qualcosa è sicuramente dovremo
riadattarsi in un modo o nell'altro o
creando nuovi bisogni o gestendo
diversamente il lavoro
auguro a tutti noi di vivere a lungo per
vederla quindi
[Applauso]